each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
thank you very much so I'm a new
lecturer at the University of Edinburgh
so before I actually start talking about
this topic I thought I briefly mentioned
some of the other stuff I'm doing mostly
because I'm trying to advertise my
general existence and potentially find
collaborators we'll see one of the
projects that I'm finishing up with the
Indiana University at the moment is on
your privacy so this is a screenshot
from linkedin linkedin allows reciprocal
information between people who view
profiles of people who own profile so if
you've ever been on linkedin it sends
you a million-one emails some of those
emails include information like who's
viewed your profile so whenever we see
reciprocal information of that type
typically it causes some level of
chilling effects so people are less
willing to interact with the profile if
they know the interaction will be closed
so one of the research projects I was
looking at that I had a graduate student
s at Indiana University that was from
Saudi Arabia was very interested in the
use of whatsapp particular the privacy
settings in Saudi Arabia this is really
interesting in terms of concerns
expectations and how people maintain
social groups particularly since
whatsapp seems to have this opinion that
if you've gotten on whatsapp you must be
a friend with every other person on
what's up and hopefully goes and uploads
your entire contact list and
automatically friends you with everyone
which is fine back when it was just your
friends but if you're a woman inside of
Saudi Arabia you cannot actually move
between two points without effectively a
cab which means that frequently you have
people in your phonebook that are in
fact cab drivers it's very common
situation and so you end up actually
sharing your phone number which is the
unique identify on what's up with a
large number of people so we did a
survey looking at the concerns and
expectations and how people were
managing these sorts of issues on what's
happened so some interesting stuff there
I just started edinboro but we're
looking at some things so one of them is
security of health apps health apps are
horrific we designed for security most
of it's because security is hard to do
quite frankly it's it's really hard to
get right and it's really hot right
hard to get right for everyone every
from an end user all the way down to a
system administrator to a developer it's
just hard across the board and so what
can we do as far as HCI to try and make
some of the building of apps easier make
them make more sense for people who
maybe don't have a four-year degree
we're in the age where apparently
everyone can code according to social
media and that's terrifying for security
how do we make it a little bit less
terrifying and similarly uh there's this
question of how do you do system
administration system administrators or
users to we seem to feel that we can
throw harder problems at them but
they're also still human and so what can
we do to support their understanding of
networks and support their management
security all right but back to the the
primary topic of this talk which is the
human factors of software updates so I
actually I did this research before this
comment came out just make the point
there but this from XKCD urgent critical
update available details fixes an issue
that was causing random laptop
electrical fires this update require
restarting your computer remind me later
this is classic and most people identify
it with it pretty well I like to think
of software updates as unsolved solved
problems so we sometimes get a problem
for example the heart heartbleed
incident from actually I'm not sure how
long ago it is now but it like just over
a year we had 600,000 vulnerable servers
to hardly good news though it's not a
massive hole that we found it's actually
very patchable so what's the first thing
we do and find a patch will what we
patch it and we release the update uh
one month later we had 300,000
vulnerable servers it's awesome we got
rid of half the vulnerable servers ah
two months later still 300,000
vulnerable servers and by one year later
it's now two hundred thousand this is a
salt problem this is not a mystery it's
not even hard to fix and yet we are
still looking at a third of the servers
online who have not patched it
so is it a linux from ability uh
actually don't I think it's linux in
fact servers is that the key thing I
don't it's asked us out openssl feels
good the basement this isn't when this
isn't characteristic of Windows updates
is right now and I'm gonna actually
bounced across Windows Update versus
other types of updates this one for
instance targets mostly windows this is
a study of 10,000 windows users done
somewhere around 2012 looking across 13
countries that's a fun number so what
you're looking at here is not everybody
really installs updates and it's really
interesting to see this graph in light
of the research i'll talk to you later
because first off that's an enormous
number of people who aren't updating but
if you look at the delta between that
and the three updates later people are
installing the updates not everybody
clearly but there is a delay and a huge
network and what's also really
interesting if you look at this table is
the list of different applications yep
so they're cooking these numbers and
that process of java right so a bunch of
these things got one installed as a
result of their craftsman that you get
through the update process right also
the US government said nasty things
about gelatin about so it's out of the
ones that still had a running how many
of them were still untouched a vision
that sounded so in the blue hat lecture
he did on that the author for the
described is as we call people up on the
phone and said will you please install
this exe that collects all this data
this is being one type of data that was
collected as pre-2012 i think microsoft
collections data more internally now
they just looked at the the exe files
one of the observations that was made at
this year's security and privacy is that
a lot of a lot of systems have multiple
versions of the same piece of software
installed installed by multiple other
pieces of software so things like adobe
reader sometimes has like four versions
and so if you try to update w/e or if
you're the best user out there you're
updating right away you still might not
have updated all the adobe readers and
that also I
ties a little bit into this I think the
question is also what the what matters I
mean there's well learnable numbers
exploded and so you look at gen gen gen
pop right look at general population
let's assume that these echoes
statistics then you look at the button
it once the case was the case there I
think you're almost sitting in a level
below where I'm at because I I do agree
that it's there's a difference between
exploitable and not but we see a lot of
things so t'adore Demetrius has some
work in this looking at the the manual
different versions and how to actually
cause exploits to variant versions so
just because it's not currently being
exploited doesn't necessarily mean it
can't be um and he is no okay the impact
of a different business of exploits
there is white and attractiveness of
these things that is widely so just you
know they're not comparable 121 in some
sense well they're both this is not the
same sponge about that is there's a
little piece impact speed of it yeah
well the more high-level work okay so
this is just me trying to demonstrate
that these are the some of the top
pieces of software that are actually
being attacked use malicious software
riders are very aware that there's a lot
of people who aren't updating Java and
they're very aware that Java is buggy
and we see where other things I mean
windows a very common piece of software
which also causes it to be a common
source of attack this is probably not
necessary for this crowd but I do this
talk in front of a lot of people with a
wide variety so we're going to a really
high level on what the heck is an update
and why do you need one I get the
feeling you kind of know this but at the
very high level an update is just
something that changes a piece of
software you used to have piece of
software a you now have place of
software be this is an example of this
happening period visually on itunes on
what this means for security is if you
have a computer and the computer has a
bunch of files installed our different
programs installed on it some of those
programs can't have whole
those are bugs or problems if you feed
in a malicious piece of if you use that
program which may not even be
internet-facing to open another file
that file can be used to trick the
system into doing something malicious
i'm using the holes an update at least
the security ones are designed to patch
the holes and provide this problem the
one time I try to do this lecture in
front of a media arts people I realized
that I desperately needed that slide but
we are more concerned with this question
which is why aren't people updating
software I'm going to talk about two
studies that were done this is an
interview study which is what I'm going
to start with and then I later did a
follow-up survey of a much larger number
of people in this study what we did was
we brought in a bunch of students from
Michigan State University we ran custom
powershell script on their machines to
pull down the logs we had them do a
short survey in the middle of the lab
and then we did a about a 40 minute
interview with them the participants
were 27 of them their aged 21 257 uh we
actually add a good female to male split
note that they are all graduate students
we tried to keep the technical ones out
but that is bias but don't mistake that
for them being security conscious out of
the 15 had at least one security problem
of some varying types 06 head either not
installed or disabled their antivirus to
it turned their firewalls off seven them
head either turned off or limited user
account control and six of them had
either turned off or limited Windows
Update ah just to make sure we all
understand how Windows Update works it
actually happens in about three phases
most of this talk is going to focus on
Windows 7 because that's what the most
common version of Windows that happened
at the time of this study so this graph
is about windows 7 windows 8 and 10 work
it similarly but not quite the same so
what happens here is a starting with
this blue box windows just goes and
automatically checks for updates it
pulls the updates down and notifies the
end user users get upset when you reboot
their computer
so it tries to give the user a time
period during which they can decide
whether or not they want to update the
software which is what this green dotted
boxes this is optional the user once
they're showing notification gets to
just think about it for about 24 hours
until 3am for windows seven anyway at
which point the system decides that the
stuff really needs to get installed
automatically installs it and then if
necessary reboots the computer this
progression is important because some
users never hit the red box they see the
notification they install the update
they didn't even know it's possible to
have it forced some users never notice
that the notification and only see the
red box and therefore assume that it
just always installs and forces them to
reboot their computer it's a common
source of confusion amongst users is a
lot calls because it does take into
account above the machine is on or not
yes it does take it out into account on
Windows Update is what I've been broadly
referring to is a triggered event so it
it automatically updates when a set of
conditions have been made in Windows 7
the primary condition is 3am I don't
know i have an experiment with laptops
enough to answer this question I've had
enough anecdotal evidence to tell you
that users are suspicious that it
updates even when it's not plugged in
that said I can't tell you whether
they're accurate or not they just tell
me that it does this and kills their
battery so I haven't had that
opportunity to experimentation so for
this study we saw most people sitting on
this standard default which is just
automatic update for participants had
set it to notify them about an update
but not automatically install it into a
disabled it entirely I'm going to start
talking briefly about the log file
analysis but I won't go into too much
depth on it but we're really interested
in two questions so
users installing updates and our users
installing updates quickly so this is
just a graph of the number of months the
user has owned the computer against the
number of updates that have been
installed this is a very rough metric
the green dots are everybody who has
automatic updates installed or set up so
they're automatically installing the
yellow dots are all users that have set
to notify and the people who turned it
off have no updates installed so they're
just not on this graph middle E this is
a little bit eyeballing but we're not
seeing in large difference between
people who are notifying and people who
are just automatically saying it which
switches us to the question of okay if
they are installing it what is the time
to patch look like researches focus yes
oh not mr. all right we do see a much
wider time to patch the top of that box
is sitting about 20 days and I mean the
automatic people both there are less of
them and so that naturally tries to
bring the box down but we're seeing them
do it faster and what's also interesting
is if you break them out so what you're
looking at here is these are all
individual participants this is based
update 30 days is the middle line if you
can't read it they're sorted by their
median update time some of the people
over on the far right like this bar
never uses this laptop and so you're
seeing a wide time to patch it's also
interesting that you're seeing for the
people who do notify they're almost
always skewed upward this is actually
following very much in language what you
would expect they're being notified
about an update sometimes they stall it
right away sometimes they delay it for a
while because they have more opportunity
to delay than the people who have the
automatic installations so the short
version we're getting out of this graph
is people are installing the updates if
given the option they are delaying the
updates
but they do actually get around to
instantly and if we switch over to
looking at this a little bit more from
the survey perspective so what people
gave us as far as structured answers
don't worry about that so we asked them
what do you think windows updates doing
on your machine on your individual
computer so do you think it's going to
notify you before it install stuff do
you think it's going to notify you after
it has installed the updates do you
think it does both of these two things
the correct answer is that does do both
depending on the settings so the people
in the green boxes are correct there's
some kind of good and Newt bad news here
the good news is that the people who had
changed their settings to notify knew
they had done it so they were there
fully aware that they were in charge of
installing these things it was not going
to automatically install and they did
know that oddly a lot of people think
that it's notifying them before it
installs the update and that it's
actually automatically installing the
update so if we kind of go back to this
diagram member i said that some people
never encounter one box or the other
because they either miss it or they
don't see it a lot of people feel that
that we need to reboot right now to
finish installing your updates dialogue
that they had on windows 7 was it asking
to upstate update right then and that
leads this situation where we see 20
users who feel that is in fact their
responsibility to decide when the
updates will be installed so okay again
this is not really news right users
don't necessarily identify this what's
interesting is we see it happen across
more than just microsoft windows so this
is Joba we were collecting the version
information from several different
applications java came up very
frequently in the interviews as this
thing that was really confusing they
didn't understand in the survey we asked
them you know are you it doesn't auto
check for updates does it auto install
the update is it not automatic at all
and do you just not have it
and we compared that to what was
actually going on on their computer
about the same story here what's
interesting is that the biggest number
here 14 feel that is their job to update
they know the system is not going to
automatically update they are fully
aware that updating can only happen when
they hit the box and yet they're not
updating and so there's a lot of
potential reasoning behind why they're
not updating but with this this graph
and the prior one basically says that
you are aware that they are the
gatekeepers to making this decision and
yet they're deciding not to make it and
so why what's actually causing that so
we did interviews here I'm going to talk
to them really fast because I did
slightly more depth in a study which I'm
going to talk to next the high level
outcomes of this work is that people
really didn't like that user interface
changing very quickly this is primarily
mentioned in terms of iTunes which had
decided to change the user interface
right before our study and this they'd
hear from their friends that this change
was going to happen and they go find how
to disable the automatic updates because
they didn't want their music to vanish
which is the way they would describe it
they didn't know what some software was
so I have a lot of great quotes by Java
what is the java why do I need a Java i
deleted the Java and then something else
broke and software that's functioning
right now so there's an American term
that if it ain't broke don't fix it and
so a lot of users had this opinion that
if they went out to go fix this thing
that was working right now it was just
going to get worse I mean it was good
now they didn't need better and if they
went fix it it was going to get worse so
this was Adobe Reader all over I have a
quote from adjustments basically it's
reading PDF files why does it need to
update why indeed so the outcome of that
led to this question of what factors do
users consider when deciding to update
or not
so in order to ask this we turn to a
survey because we wanted wider set than
37 graduate students to get a better
sense so we use Mechanical Turk with
this standard limitations that apply
namely that these are slightly more
technically savvy users when it comes to
interacting with the internet we asked
them if they felt that they ask other
people for help and if they feel that
other people ask them for help as a
measurement of skill I can tell you they
all think that other people ask them for
help and they never ask anyone according
to them with some minor exceptions so we
got 307 responses so the way this survey
worked is first we ask them some
demographics questions and then we just
ask them to tell us a story about a
software update event we tried to be
very general but we made it very clear
that they could tell us a good story a
bad story just tell us about something
to happen to you involving the software
updates we then ask them 17 follow-up
questions about that experience
including whether they consider to be a
positive or negative experience how they
became aware of the update why they did
or did not install this particular piece
of software what made them decision and
then after that we asked them to tell us
the opposite of what they told us before
so if they told us a positive story
before we asked them if they could
please tell us a negative story we
correctly predicted that most of them
would tell us- stories beforehand about
two-thirds decided to select a negative
story and we wanted to also understand
what makes an update a positive
experience not just a negative one so
I'm going to focus on some of the high
level results of that this is actually
still being written up in a paper that
hopefully will get submitted soon
there's a lot of interesting things here
that aren't going to be necessary
presented one of the key ones is the
dropout during the process of updating
so we think of updating frequently as
just that one dialogue but as I'll time
to talk about it as I go through these
updating is in fact an enormous process
starting from becoming aware of the
update after you do various preparations
in advance of the update getting locked
down in a specific
okay Shin well it does the update and
then dealing with some of the
after-effects of it and you'll kind of
see that in some of the discussion here
the four things that I think are really
interesting coming out of this though is
first off that reputation really matters
people are really concerned about
whether or not it's worth the bother of
updating resource consumption with a
major concern and then one of the
interesting if somewhat minor findings
is this whole conflation between updates
and viruses so we'll go through those
people research updates a shocking
number of people research updates this
is by no means a large percentage of my
data set we're looking at close to Julie
ten or fifteen percent but they are
still talking a lot about updating and
asking their friends asking the internet
looking at reviews looking up these kind
of reviews generally trying to figure
out what does this thing do what's it
gonna do I mean stuff like from this guy
reading my text you can keep the bugs so
people are really concerned about these
sorts of things and what they were
mostly looking for when they were
looking at recommendations are changes
to features so what people are concerned
about this right when people who
self-select to publish these reviews are
concerned about this but in a general
setting what percentage of people or
indeed concerned about these these kinds
of issues especially the non-technical
one speech as you mentioned and Turk
well it gets it gets you some bread was
a mixed bag it is definitely mixed bag
the other key thing to note here is
we're not actually looking at percentage
of update offense we're looking at
things that are most salient to end
users so when I ask you for a story what
is the story you think of first it's a
decent representation of that it's a
horrible representation of what the
actual percentage of events are your
life because you're you're responding
based on what you most remember that
said if I were to ask you for a story if
I was your friend it's also the store
you're most likely to relate and if you
were to think back on the last event
when trying to decide what you're doing
next it's something you might think of
or remember so it's kind of a
positioning
this work in that regards I can't tell
you what percentage of people in what
percentage of time actually do reviewing
I can tell you from the tone of the
stories that we I know the percentage of
people who responded about it Mike even
had a cheat sheet okay I can't find him
ask me later and I will give you the
actual percentage because we asked
people in the follow-up survey for the
first story whether or not they had
researched we didn't even just wait for
them to respond here on when they're
talking about things they don't always
discuss it more frequently say oh I
heard or oh I saw or I went to go check
this out or I glanced these sorts of
reviews on when I say research I mean it
very broadly I include like my friend
installed this and told me was awful but
this kind of words it's a little mix of
reputation and things and there are some
things that people were really willing
to spend the time so particularly
jailbroken devices they weren't updating
until the jailbreak was going to work on
the other side of the update and they
were very clear about this so key
features that they really cared about if
there's a particular feature they really
cared about they would go research
before the update there was a lot of
people there were a lot of people that
just updated to see what just because
you're supposed to but for those that
did research these are the things they
were concerned about was it more buggy
is they going to eat more of my battery
I decided that I wasn't going to install
the update because I've heard all the
reviews online about how it generally
makes your phone slower in every respect
so this is a common sort of statement
that I would get in stories is it worth
the bother so here's dogbert the product
designer I created an operating system
that uses eighty percent of your time
begging for updates that still leaves a
healthy twenty percent of your time to
reboot your computer over and over of
course it's boss asked if it also faxes
but this was a common statement so we
hear a lot about you know I hate reboots
I hate all these other sorts of things
but the key undertone that you heard a
lot is is this
going to be worth the amount of effort
I'm about to put into it and it does
actually require a fair amount of effort
in some case when considering this they
worry about things like how important is
the software so people understand that
their antivirus is important and they'll
say that they don't think itunes is
important because they don't use it very
often it might be a common comment
effort required to do the installation
the risk of the installation the amount
of disruption which is where most three
boots its but sometimes it disrupts
another sorts of ways so this user hit
most of them I generally do not update
iTunes because I think there are too
many of them and I don't regularly use
the software so I I'm also annoyed by
the fact there's another program update
added to the prompt so I have to uncheck
it since it downloads junk software onto
my computer otherwise related to why the
Jumbo it is also less people good job is
fascinating because Java just switched
Java used to install the ask toolbar
which Microsoft now consider some
versions of which to be a virus and
removes it and as just switched to now
altering your default search engine to
yahoo and I will get back to that in a
moment because this is such an exciting
topic resources resources were a serious
concern particularly in terms of
delaying so if we want to talk about why
users to play and someone mentioned it
earlier that even windows itself
respects the battery life and will
attempt to delay an update until that
resource is available so we see things
like okay there's a download coming so I
better backup stuff before I even try
this because it eats all my drive space
particularly if I'm on a budget device
like an iPhone to get a budget end of an
iphone and this is also an issue with
data plan limits so it actually costs a
lot of money for me to get this update
down on to my device it gets even more
fun when my device isn't mobile so I
have some users talk about how they have
to visit the library or some other
public place in order to get the Wi-Fi
necessary to pull down the updates on
their mobile devices and then
I have a couple stories about a devices
such as Xbox this isn't ps2's that
aren't connected to the internet because
they don't have internet home so these
whole epic stories about how this person
went to the friends house downloaded an
update on to a USB Drive went back to
their house plugged it in it didn't work
for some reason and then somewhere in
the middle of this whole process gave up
decided wasn't me that important of an
update and so for non mobile devices
which advises that can't be moved on to
one of these locations we see long
delays of these sorts of things so I
first had to delete half the apps on my
phone and I also uploaded my pictures to
my computer and delete them off of my
phone because I didn't have enough usage
to install the update iPhone user common
problem researchers are also a major
issue while installing the update this
is where we hid battery power processing
power locked out of using devices so it
costs processing power some of these
devices are overloaded at the given
moment so if i install an update in the
background you assume that oh they must
have that much background processor free
I've several users that basically
explained how their system just
mysteriously came to a crawl and they
couldn't figure out what to do about the
situation until they finally figured out
that Windows Update was doing this and
so they went into the update settings
and changed them to notify because it
was not worth the delay to their job
that this was causing because even
though it was a background update their
system was too laden to handle a
background update Windows Update drains
my processing resources preventing
backups and even stopping me from
running stat software for my job so this
type of thing happened and not just for
windows okay so now we're going to get
back to your comment a little bit
updates contain viruses this is not a
large percentage of my story data set
but is such an interesting percentage
will talk of addicts we're also talking
about it because when I present this to
undergrads not this research
specifically but how to be safe online I
get this question from some random
member of the audience oh but I heard
update since to involve viruses and this
happens to me often enough
that this slide is now up here I
honestly could not tell if it was
trustworthy I did not know if I should
accept it or not I chose not and it was
a wise choice as a friend told me later
that it was a virus I have no idea how
this friend would know this I'm betting
you that the person describes something
that looked like it came off the
internet and the friend just decided
that things off the internet are bad
became very hesitant and did not install
windows update due to a virus that
exploded windows update and allowed and
proper code to be signed to Microsoft
certificates this resulted in multiple
rootkit virus that was compromised by
the system if I remember correctly this
was a particular one off news article
they went out but this user actually
absorbed that data and solve that
problem by turning off windows update
because it's dangerous and updates
contain viruses alright so we have that
problem which is just a general problem
but it's actually being conflated a lot
by the bundled software affairs fairness
they're not exactly looking for yet to
hear in that some social engineering
attacks do in fact pretend to be update
like you are to be a bit you know that
they put up is update like you guys in
this is actually excellent way to get to
drop wineries in the system it's
actually worse than that um so if you
look at Adobe or Nigel um Android
particularly I'm a one-off developer in
android I've made this shiny new
flashlight app that's actually
respecting your privacy by the way
flashlights are sanely dangerous on
Android don't install them but I've made
a new one you really like it I've got a
whole pile of users and so some company
comes in and says oh i'll offer you six
thousand dollars for this app and you're
like oh pay dirt and so you you hand
over the credentials you get your six
thousand dollars and they install
malware on that many devices overnight
with no warning and in that regard yeah
we're looking at combination of it's not
clear when something is or is not a
valid update i had several the stories
feature a situation which an update pop
they closed it and then they went and
found the homepage and installed it
we're looking at em Turk users there a
little bit more nervous about these
things but again we're looking at those
sorts of channel attacks and while this
may be a one-off news article it's did
happen I've been told by security
professionals that actually one of the
fun things to attack is Wireshark if you
can break into the Wireshark update
chain oh boy those are fun computers a
wire shark is a network analysis tool
it's used almost entirely by system
administrator type people the people
that have the better credentials to
steal all right so bundled software this
is interesting so in case you don't know
what bundled software is this is the
best example I could find for you flash
would love it if you also installed the
mcafee security plus tool this is some
people describe this as a blocking
problem for them not because it's
impossible to uncheck these boxes but
because if you screw up you end up
wasting several hours of your life
undoing the problem and because of that
even though this is a low effort it's
high risk and so if you don't see a good
reason to do it I taught some people are
like I just don't even try because if I
did it's just not worth it and so they
delay it or they just don't update at
all but it gets a little bit better so
the update for QuickTime gave me
problems because it comes with an add-on
software some of the software has
viruses and can harm the computer it
also has redirects and takes over search
engines I decide not to update from them
unless I really need it so if you think
about what a virus looks like to an
average end user what did viruses do
they put up pop-ups they change your
search engine they change your home page
this is the sort of behavior of a virus
I had a informatics professor show up in
my office right after Mozilla decided to
change the default search engine to
Yahoo because he was desperately
concerned he had a virus on his machine
why viruses do things like that and so
well you're actually seeing
healy with Java as it was brought up
earlier when you see things that uh were
updates or emulating virus type activity
it's actually causing a learning
feedback loop to some degree for end
users that oops I install the virus
that's what a virus looks like these
things contain viruses and you start
ending what up with that particular me
that's it thankfully I didn't actually
see that many stories that cover this
but as I said a surprising number of
undergrads are concerned about it so
it's interesting so what can we do out
of this one interesting question is how
do we support things like review
behavior so people are really interested
in going out and finding information
about these updates what can we do to
either support than finding of
information by presenting information
that's more interesting or supporting
them through providing more feedback to
the reviews so if you look at reviews
for updates they're actually pretty
minimal compared to say something like
what you see on Amazon or any of these
other sites that do reviewing it would
be nice if we can actually provide some
accurate real-time information to users
I know we can't tell upfront whether or
not an update will reboot your machine
because we don't know what will be in
memory at the time of the installation
it'd be nice if I knew before I hit the
Update button if I'm going to need to
reboot my machine it also be nice to
know of how much I actually use
something there are a lot of clients
eyes statistics that might be very
assistive to an end user when they're
attempting to make these decisions this
is almost an impossible problem but how
do we clarify which updates are actually
updates in which of them are actually
viruses or malicious it'd be interesting
to see a discussion of workflows I see
some users who talk about oh I really
wanted to get user software right now
and then I see other users are like yeah
I really need to use that software right
now so I minimize the update window and
when I finished using the software I hit
the button to update I have seen very
few interfaces that actually allow
options such as installed us as soon as
I am finish in both the studies you
describe you don't look at the temporal
characteristics
when people are updating and I wondered
I don't think I'll be both very
revealing it but when would be the best
time to there's actually a good question
I'm trying to think if I did look at any
of that in the data I did ask people
where they were physically located and
how busy they were but I wasn't really
seeing any good correlations between
that and some of the contents of the
stories the biggest problem is that when
i asked for story type data as stories
usually encompass multiple updates over
a long time frame to form a full and
cohesive story and so some of the
questions about like where were you did
really make sense to end users which is
why i haven't really dealt with that
data and a little bit of what I've been
talking about a lot of people will delay
till they have a moment but I can't
quantify what that is at the moment so
it's an interesting question certain
things are best done in the dark you
know so I mean the latest mac OS think
is basically do the switch there's do
tonight and do the moral kind of thing
and I think they kind of go and sense
when you're not using the machine to
figure out one tonight is for you and
then on the windows side it's a
four-hour window which is pretty far out
and oftentimes pushes you into nighttime
anyhow so I mean it's sort of i think
there will be a spike of dollars it's my
suspicion angry actually might have so
little bit of that data for my 37
subjects but they're also grad students
and when tinnitus might be a little
different point i'm particularly
interested in whether you think users
differentiate of different levels of
trust associate with the different
providers yeah i think i'm not even
hesitating I mean I I don't know if I
have quite the right data state that in
a publication but I would one of the
studies i would like to rhyme as soon as
i get a grad student to run it would
look huh where are we where are we
you're actually not doing too bad so if
you look at from an air bars perspective
apple's sitting around here ranging from
oh thank god I've been wanting that new
shiny thing to Apple screws
everything up wants me to buy a new
device and I never update their stuff
Microsoft is kind of sitting in the in
bama ambivalent midi middle people hate
the reboots this is not news but broadly
they don't seem to find the updates to
be that problematic but one of the big
reasons they don't is that you provide
an ability to revert so the tone here is
a little bit that there's a safety net
when things go wrong so what happens and
you see this as stories particularly
ones featuring a Microsoft Update
failure so what will happen is that
they'll try to update something will go
horribly wrong that describe how
horrible it was and then they'll explain
that they just reverted the system and
didn't update for the next week users
also have a lot of faith in company's
ability to work out bugs so the strong
differentiation between they think the
company put in there on purpose and what
they think the company put in there on
accident so if they think they put the
company put that in by accident then
their reaction to something negative
online is oh I'm going to wait a couple
days because they have faith that
developers will fix those sorts of
problems if they think that Apple
purposefully turned off the support for
their first generation ipod they don't
think that they're going to sort that
out and as a result they just disable
all the updates the the build trust is
an interesting thing because you very
rarely do I see statements like updates
just cause problems usually I see
statements like Java is awful or
Microsoft picks the worst times for
rebooting my computer they're almost all
pre pendant with a statement from a
particular company or a particular
software brand they seem to have a very
strong now what I'm not sure is if that
carries through into the app type model
I saw a little bit of that naps but it's
not strong enough usually I'll see
things like Oh app updates on my iPhone
are fine they'll particularly call it
the iphone but they won't necessarily
pull out and I don't know
focusing communitech sure I mean like
rage and all of that is great but does
it actually affect things so like can
you line it up with the stock price or
something I mean in the case of Adobe
more seriously though in the last year
alone we've seen so many CDs release
that I'm the poor company frankly is in
the gutter Java is not a boon for oracle
at this point at all i mean i think we
are probably doing okay on that front at
least down in that like 99 2000 that was
a different story but my sense is that
those so smaller if you were like in the
case of adobe especially companies do
bear the grant of a lot of this
negativity to a point where it's like a
measurable effect there's a very
interesting presentation by the person
in adobe in charge of update at said ha
whatever the op date workshop is and I'm
spacing on the name of it hasn't run for
a couple years in which he tried to
explain why it was Adobe wasn't
automatically updating because you think
that this would solve the problem if we
just automatically updated it's a really
interesting talk that he gives because
when his primary reason is actually
legal in a lot of countries it's illegal
to just reach into someone's computer
change the code without telling them
they call that hacking and so the there
was a deep concern initially before
Microsoft started really testing these
waters about the safety for a company
about going and pushing these automatic
updates out and so if you look at who
started doing the automatic updating
first it had less to do with like you
know who is innovative about this
concept and more to do with who had
enough lawyers to back up the problem
and so you look at it right Microsoft's
did this first and they did it much like
they they kind of put their toe in to
some degree air until all the way now we
hit Windows 10 where you can't turn it
off if you're a home user and I'm
fascinated to see how that turns out to
like Google try it next and then we
didn't even c java doing this to like
two or three years ago you think java is
the most invisible thing to our users
the smartest thing to automatic update
in many case
unless you're on a corporate network or
a couple things but most of those people
know to turn off the updates for their
devices but they weren't willing to do
it and Adobe wasn't willing to do it
because they were concerned about the
legal implications so now we're seeing
Adobe which merely has enormous no
problems starting to push the automatic
route for a long time Adobe actually had
this policy if you read their
documentation where they would
automatically download the update and
then wait 30 days before it wouldn't
automatically install it so if you
didn't get around to installing it for
30 days it would auto install because
they were trying to provide the most
amount of notification to an end user so
it's kind of a roundabout answer to your
question um so something to do this
don't need to have a horrible property
this book sequence in order to pre cash
some stuff and the consequence of this
was that if you install the module be
updated was essential that you had to
reboot immediately your Windows computer
and so this 30-day blade thing a lot of
what they were doing basically was
hoping that you would reboot your
computer for some other reason within
those 30 days at which point they would
grab it I know that that's actually very
interesting thank you I didn't know that
one um I will the other part of his talk
that I thought was just kind of
hilarious is apparently they had some
security hole they patched it they
pushed it out he described it is waiting
for the other shoe to drop for someone
to find they start exploiting this and
then he got a phone call from one of
their data centers who was according to
them almost experiencing a ddos level
attack on this particular update patch
and it turned out that someone had used
it to steal world of warcraft players
accounts and so people were actually
driving home from work to patch this
piece of software because it was like
the patch was out on all the forums like
you better do this right now but it took
him a lot of figure it out but he never
had a detox level attack on is like on
the update channel before so it's kind
of interesting okay anyway so one of the
outcomes it's not quite there that I'd
like to take this work
is how do we communicate what's actually
happening an update to and end users and
I like to think of this is kind of like
the the five questions so if we were to
answer five questions on every update
interface what should they be what what
information is most important to an end
user to know and if we were to do
something like a review website like I
see review websites for clothing they
ask things like was this the size it
claimed to be was this the color it
claimed to be uh or if you go on to a
travel website was the hotel clean like
what are those standard questions and so
one of the things I'm trying to pull out
is what those questions should be and
this is an initial attempt but from the
resource downloads like how big is this
upload as this download file like how
many resources is how much resources
will it take to install how long will
this update take to install on my
computer I realize that's a very
challenging question to answer what one
of the worst things I saw from people
was we tried to code for how long the
updates were taking which totally failed
because some people think 10 minutes way
too long and some people think 30
minutes is just fine but the thing that
made it most negative was when it was
outside of their expectations so I don't
mean an accurate prediction I mean a
ballpark how long am I going to be tied
down to this one spot that has wireless
is it going to be an hour is it going to
be two hours is going to be 10 minutes
will a reboot be needed like how much
basically how much of a bother is this
going to be to me well this is this a
silent update so a lot of the security
updates are effectively silent right
they don't change anything is this going
to change anything I see and how will
this update impact performance and that
last question is the one that they are
least likely to believe from the
developer but might be really
interesting to see on a review site on
how people are viewing the performance
changes up or down um yeah so going
forward him I thought you we know so
much about the computer I mean
reversibly logs and Microsoft whether
the vendor
together that understands you think you
could have a predictive model of that
but one of the things that would be
really fascinating to take is the next
step here is to just go and create a
variation of the Wix installer where you
just create a on of the Wits installer
be enough but try to take one of the
common pieces of installation code Wix
being an example of that and try to
build in the answers to some of these
sorts of questions so this might be a
little bit too much for wickes to figure
out but you're right i'm lee like i
don't know why we don't look at how to
do this and maybe someone does and i
just haven't made the connection yet but
these are the serious concerns that
honestly I can't ask a developer I can't
say you know can you tell me how long
this will take down this arbitrary
person's computer we don't necessarily
know some of the computers are horribly
lading yeah actually that's a good one
I've heard that one a lot by the way the
revert capability on Windows is heavily
used not just for Windows updates also
asked prior to choosing to update okay
also there must be things that we can
deliver to the user post post up in like
like the empty to revert or other kinds
of feedback about what's just happened
maybe highlighting things that are not
different or you know giving these are
more sir richer information at that
point so there was a /a a big dread
which take that with a grain of salt
basically complaining you know I had
this appt yesterday it's not working
today what do I do about this kind of
ash / thing in this long complained
thread which I actually read through
which I tried to not normally do a
slashdot but it was really interesting
because reverting was one of the top
things on the complaints I had this appt
yesterday why can't I just go back to
the way it was working yesterday and
there was in some cases that's possible
but we're starting to see a lot more
situations with servers right so my app
doesn't work in isolation it works in
relation to this API and so both of
those things need to be functioning and
one of them will just stop supporting
the situation
after a while and so it is interesting
to ask whether or not reverting is
possible through the app on and maybe
even a way to inform a user what the
time of life is of their current one so
I meet a lot of professors actually that
have disabled updates for the length of
the semester and then tell me that they
just their computer just does all of
that about two weeks after the grades
are due because they can't afford
everything going wrong during the
semester they're way too busy and so
there's this little bit of gap of like
people okay I just need to put it off
for a while well how long can you
actually put this off before you start
seeing maybe non security level problems
with the app or the API by the way this
is pretty much all my talk the next
slide after the next one is the
questions one so if we have questions
it's fun actually I think I've gone
through everything with that so we're at
the questions but I'm going to go back
to the slide cuz we seem to be more
interested in it so any other questions
um feminine it seems like asking users
about some of these features if you will
while it's valuable it has almost no way
to get at the part of the methods of
this big which is the benefit of the
update which is largely invisible sasuke
pipes like asking the patient well do
you like this doctor they'll say oh they
have wonderful bedside manner and there
are offices are clean and they gave me a
lollipop which is great but it doesn't
tell you you think about the actual
quality of service when when it is
spotted the problem will save their life
right so can we get at the deeper level
here by asking you this question so is
that out of there we have to remember
users are in both ends of the sub day
one user is the one consuming the update
but one of them is generating it so if
you think of it if software developers I
think of them as user sometimes but
they're different style of user so the
the result of this research kind of goes
in both of those directions so on one
hand how do we phrase this to an end
user such that they're more likely want
it but on the other hand what is it the
end users are worrying about can be
translated backwards I'll give you an
example actually from iTunes so we the
first study I did we it takes a long
time to interview people so the length
of this interview process is about a
month and a half itunes helpfully
released an update with a massive user
interface change on like right before
our initial interviews and then a month
and a half later you know we finish our
interviews so it turns out what they do
is they released a patch that was 160
some security vulnerabilities and they
had done it about two weeks before they
released the major you eye patch so when
I interview people all of them has all
the security updates no problems at all
the UI updates for the first batch of
users they were terrified when user
described it as oh my god where'd my
music go I went back up and you know I
blocked everything I told all my friends
to block everything a month and a half
later the sentences I was hearing or a
little different there were closer to I
saw my friend using this I now feel like
I know how to interact with it itunes
had gone and switched between us
sidebar interviews to a modal interface
which is a major you I changed and so
some users didn't even know how to
access their music right off so watch
change watching their friends interact
with it kind of made them feel more
comfortable about it and then by the end
of the interviews I was like well you
know it didn't look too bad i installed
it I've reactivated it I bought a new
iphone that requires me to have the
latest one so I've installed it when
you're looking at large changes that
aren't bug base the more like user
interface feature changes there's kind
of an adjustment time period so one of
the ways you can adapt this toward
security is doing what they did there
which is release all the security
updates with a small time lag users get
those installed they have the gut
reaction to the UI change they kind of
get over it as many of them that are
going to and then you start releasing
the security updates again so that's one
way you can take this type of research
and apply it more in the software
engineering direction i'm thinking more
about how you are bundling the updates
and what goes into each update so if we
can take this things we really want
people to install and bundle them in a
separate update from the things that
people really worried about it's fine is
also a point of advertisement so when
you look at some of these interfaces for
updates you kind of see a bad example of
this but they they kind of are getting
some of these messages they say the
words improve performance they say like
when you're looking at what your app
actually does there's certain things you
can pull out and say okay what is it the
users really care about here well I put
out a performance app that also happens
to have the security thing and users are
more likely to pay attention to that
that's worth the bother so there's a
little bit of marketing there there's
some really almost no research and how
to explain that this is security update
and get users to care about it because
it's invisible the only example i have
is somebody who decided to create an
application on windows that puts
graffiti on the screen slowly as the
apps on the device gets older but um
well fun I don't think that's
necessarily going to work for most users
so I don't actually have a good answer
for this I'm kind of working on it as
part of the answer
and the other part is this sentence I
hear from users which is I installed
this thing nothing changed was it really
worth the risk so we need some way to
communicate that something changed or we
need to communicate what other risk you
just countered like I would love to see
a study in which we just took the most
recent news article from someplace and
said this is what it's countering if you
want to be safe from this problem this
thing that just showed up in the New
York Times that's what this update does
and I don't know what that would do but
it would be an interesting study given
the update does he you need to know that
there was something very by him nothing
changed is just saying TQ in a way
hopefully Microsoft is somewhat unique
in that you allow multiple update
channels it's possible to install
security updates without installing
other updates that's rare most updates
are cumulative so you at the moment they
block the UI update they've blocked
everything it's not just the security
update people also tend to be a bit more
improvement this is where we come back
to trust so if you are actually doing
what you say then you just have no
problems with even the iTunes where they
have strong opinions about itunes they
will happily install the security update
so that's the slightest bit of concern
because apples managed to convince them
that the security updates don't screw
things up or when they do they
immediately fix it again we forgive bugs
some degree so if you can convince you
user that your security updates will
actually not mess anything up and you
build that trust relationship then yeah
you should just push them silently and
it totally works there's usually
something I say here about disabled
users so I've interviewed one blind user
that was explaining to me how every
update on hermas whole machine is turned
off because she loses the ability to
even fix the machine if it updates and
it messes up her screen reader so she
needs to select very specific times
either when her screen reader software
approves the update or when she's in the
presence of someone who can assist her
with the fixing of the machine if
something goes wrong because
it's a very serious problem for so it's
kind of this mashup between yeah
automatic updates if we can do them
safely and quietly and silently go ahead
we should get them away from users but
we do need a little bit of catch in
there for some of these other groups
that do need it but it's not the main
group all right any other questions